un giro drástico en las investigaciones
que avanzan contra el ex presidente de
la anp el fbi y allanó la residencia del
magnate de mar al agua el lunes en una
operación sobre la que la oficina
federal de investigación y el propio
departamento de justicia siguen sin
entregar detalles lo que se sabe es que
fue una redada que se hizo en el marco
de una investigación del departamento de
justicia a raíz de que en febrero los
archivos nacionales de administración de
documentos anunciaron que habían
recuperado 15 cajas que incluyen
documentos clasificados y que se
encontraban en mal halago se busca de
esclarecer si trama se quedó con
información confidencial de la casa
blanca justo cuando tanto el congreso
como el departamento de justicia
investigan del antiguo mandatario por su
papel en la toma del capitolio en enero
de 2021 las pesquisas llegan en un
momento en el que está noche está
jugando un papel clave en las primarias
del partido republicano de cara a las
elecciones legislativas de noviembre y
mostrándose como un posible candidato
presidencial para 2024 para la formación
conservadora hay motivos políticos
detrás de la redada
ahora encontramos que la justicia en
eeuu no es equitativa está determinada
según sí quieres ir o no detrás de una
figura política voces republicanas han
cargado contra el fiscal general merrick
garland que en el pasado incluso ha sido
criticado por los demócratas por su
pasividad en las investigaciones por el
asalto al capitolio el silencio de
garland deja muchas preguntas en el aire
como por ejemplo fue una coincidencia
que trump estuviera nueva york' en el
momento de la redada mientras tanto
desde la casa blanca aseguran que el
presidente yo vaivén no sabía de la
operación
el presidente no fue informado no estaba
al tanto nadie en la casa blanca recibió
un aviso que ven a gente en este
panorama el representante de republicano
scott barry denunció que agentes del fbi
le confiscaron su teléfono celular el
martes perry fue uno de los políticos
que ayudó a trump a difundir la falsa
proclama de un fraude electoral en 2020
en hechos que luego llevaron a la toma
del capitolio en 2021 por su parte trump
dedicó el martes a enviar mensajes de
texto y correos electrónicos pidiendo
financiación para defenderse de la que
dice es una casa de brujas en su contra